the two most profitable strategies for
acquiring customers if you don't have
tons of cash and you're not funded
Beyond just creating content and
creating a brand is to get Word of Mouth
which is referrals it's not just having
a very good product which is important
but reminding and encouraging people to
share it my podcast I just decided to
say hey guys if you could leave a review
and share this with somebody that would
be great we 20x the number of reviews
that we were getting and our growth
skyrocketed if you remind them at least
they're more likely to do the second way
is through Affiliates which means other
businesses or groups that have your
desired audience that's where if I was a
yogurt store I would go find those
groups and you say hey anybody who goes
to your clothing store I'll give them a
free yogurt you just enhance the value
of what they're selling and you let a
hundred businesses carry you as they
flood you with all their customers a you
just have to make it good enough that it
benefits the customer and B that the
Affiliates actual thing becomes more
valuable with the addition of your thing
too